hey everyone this is steve blanchov with
collider and i am thrilled to be with
all of you guys talking about lord of
the rings rings of power um uh this is
my most
you guys i this is my
your show is the thing that i'm most
looking forward to this year i the
footage i've seen you know especially
the trailer today is incredible um i
just want to say that it looks like from
from my perspective that amazon just
basically said here's our money go do
what you want to do because it looks
like a movie uh it looks incredible what
can you tell people in terms of
like the spectacle of this show i think
i think the the show is so beloved in
the fantasy and the works are so
complete and rich and there's such a
emotional
attachment to it that i think
it was more like what resources do we
need to make this you know the resources
were there and the resource resources
kept coming so that we could truly uh
make the show that needed to be made you
know and show what needed to be shown
yeah i don't think people would want the
budget version of this show i think that
would be upsetting so you do you know
like as well said you need the resources
to sort of fully realize this and
you know we've been fortunate enough to
watch the first three episodes and
i promise you
it is it surpasses you know anything we
could have hoped for and we were there
we were there making it and it still
really like blew us away one of the
things that i think is great about this
is that listen i love the lord of the
rings movies i love the extended
editions they're my favorite part
because it gave more time to all the
characters and the thing that i'm so
excited about this series is that
because it's a series you can actually
have like conversations that take a few
minutes you don't have to rush to the
next scene that's why i'm so excited
it's eight hours to tell the story can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the show that having this much time
really lets you develop these characters
i guess it's not all about story
you know it's it's more also about
character development and being able to
sit with these characters and fall in
love with them and not necessarily have
to be driven by story
but we are
there
there's obviously story but there's also
about there's times that actually
no okay i'm mentioning my words
no but i said well
let's go on oh god no i just think that
there's also time with these characters
you know and and instead of it just
being like okay next next next next next
next gotta get to this point you have
time for these characters to develop and
to fall in love with them
yeah i mean i'd say
watching so one of the things that was
amazing when we got a chance to see more
of the work is that there are storylines
that we weren't involved with that we
haven't seen any work of so i was able
to watch characters who haven't seen on
camera at all
and when you watch those that's when you
get this character understanding this
character development and for me i found
it really moving to watch these actors
portray these often canon characters and
sometimes not
but to go whoa whoa i'm falling i'm with
this person i want to know what's going
on and that's only because we're seeing
inside their souls more because of the
time so that's what i think is the heart
of your question and i agree with what
you've said i think it's really
important
thank you daniel
um so you guys mentioned you've seen the
first three episodes obviously you're on
set you witnessed everything happening
but the vfx are a huge part of something
like this talk a little bit about um
what i guess talk about the first three
episodes and what you saw that you can't
wait for fans to see in them i think
numenor is like the most exciting thing
because that hasn't been realized on
screen yet and even when we were
shooting most of it was like practical
is that there were vistas in the
background that we never saw but like
even watching the third episode i think
i i was
bowled over by what numenor looks like
even though i was on that set
um i think i think it's gorgeous i was
just gonna say what was that you were
talking about an alleyway that you stood
in you tell that because that was
amazing when you yeah i mean uh ramsay
avery the the production designer on
this like built not the whole city but
like a massive chunk of it and there's
like little alleyways in it and uh like
the details are so beautiful um there's
a numenorean graffiti over old elvish
which if you know the story is is a
beautiful detail um that uh only like a
keenly look you know like someone with
eagle eyes will
notice um yeah it's stunning so yeah
numerous is the most exciting thing
we're not we're not
we're not oh
no but it is it is
stunning i mean i was i gasped it is
such a the build itself that's the thing
we did the show and we still are
watching the show and we are
floored by it so i i cannot wait for
people to see that and they did put a
lot of the the amount of artists that
worked on this
specialists artisans
you see it all over the show the
mythology some of our costumes i don't
know if you you guys but i'm sure like
we had elements under elements that were
never going to be seen and they were
still crafted to like the last detail
and we felt that we felt that in our
performance as well
everyone associated florida rings with
new zealand and the second season's
gonna be filming in england what is your
what are you
excited for i guess with the season two
going to england are you sort of like is
it weird are you you know what i mean
like well i think people associate the
films with new zealand but if you go to
the the literature if you go to tolkien
and his works it is very english
mythology so i think it's actually going
to be interesting
to have the opportunity to you know
really show some of that uh part of
the world in terms of locations and and
the talent that's there
um you know i think it's good i think
it's going to keep it fresh and i think
you know it'll keep
it will keep us on our toes
um
but in terms of our time in new zealand
the end result and what we're going to
show the world
we get to really share new zealand and
its beauty so we still you know get to
sort of present new zealand in that way
but tolkien and and the uk i feel like
are very much intertwined i think
sometimes people forget that because
again it's it's really the films that
that sort of you made as you were saying
it i'm like oh yeah you're on
like i
really messed that up i was like yeah
that's a big effort you didn't mess
um hypothetically speaking when do you
start filming season two what
yeah i don't do anything with my face
they can't edit their reaction
um i think i mean as you know the show
is uh it's protected and it protects the
the the there's a function to the
protection of the mystery um so i don't
think you're gonna get any answers from
us about that and uh but just so that
you know it's there's a reason to that
and once you see the episodes you'll
understand why this mystery has been so
protected so that we you can have as
much wonder and experience as much magic
as we have i got too close to digging i
was like at the dwarf
you did well you did well
listen i'm gonna
stop here i'm just gonna say sincerely i
cannot wait to talk to you again when i
can talk about the specifics of the
episodes i wish you guys nothing but the
best thank you so much thank you